[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOLENE TEO: Hey, everyone.
I'm Jolene Teo, and
I'm a customer engineer
at Google Cloud.
And welcome back to the
Google Cloud Technical
Guides for Startups, where we
are creating a series of videos
for technical enablement to
help startups to start, build,
and grow your businesses
successfully and sustainably
on Google Cloud.
In our previous
episode, we showed you
how you can get started
on Google Cloud.
Today, we'll be moving
on to our third stop,
streamlining
application development.
We'll be covering
first the basics
of what exactly is serverless.
And following that,
I'll be introducing
to you the portfolio
of solutions available
and when to choose which.
I'll then share with you a
little bit more about Cloud Run
and also run through
a demo as well.
Right after, I'll
be sharing with you
some tips on how you can
optimize both performance as
well as cost.
And last but not
least, we'll be running
through a simple application
of an e-commerce platform
together, as well as
a customer case study.
We'll then wrap up
with some of the links
that you can follow up with
right after this video.
So come on now, let's explore
the land of the serverless
together.
First of all, we need
to get our basics right.
What does serverless mean?
When you make use of a
serverless infrastructure,
it means that you are
able to deploy and scale
your applications more quickly
and securely in a fully
managed environment.
This also means
that your developers
can focus on writing the code
instead of having to worry
about the infrastructure.
This leads to faster time to
market, which is definitely
important for startups.
On top of that, your
workloads will automatically
scale according to the
traffic, and you only
need to pay for
what you consume.
All in all, this enables
faster and more secure
development, deployment,
as well as operations.
Now that we have the
basics sorted out,
let me share with you
how Google Cloud can
help you to streamline your
application development.
So first up, we have Cloud Run.
Now, Cloud Run is
really great for running
any form of applications
or containers
in a fully managed environment.
Next we have Cloud
Functions, which
is definitely great for any
event-driven applications.
And last but not least,
we have App Engine,
which also can help
to run applications
in a fully managed environment.
I'm pretty sure you must be
wondering when to choose which.
Well, I've got your back.
Here are some of the
most common use cases
being compiled together
for you to help you
with your product
decision making.
And now, we're going to zoom in
to the latest addition, as well
as a very popular one,
which is Cloud Run.
Cloud Run enables you to run
your containerised applications
on a managed compute platform
quickly and securely,
bringing you from containers
to production within seconds.
Write your code your way,
using your favorite languages,
such as Python, Ruby,
Go, and many more.
Not only that, with
Cloud Run you only
have to pay for the resources
that your startup consumes.
And this means that
you won't have to pay
for overprovisioned resources.
Cloud Run is also built upon
the open standard Knative,
which ensures the portability
of your applications.
And all of the above allows
you to build your applications
the way you want to.
Right, it's about time
to give you a tour.
Now on to the demo.
In this demonstration, we'll
be creating a Cloud Run service
with the use of a container
image being built.
We will then explore versioning,
as well as traffic splitting.
Now for today,
we'll be making use
of a simple application, which
is a simple meme generator
service.
How it works is that it takes
in an upper text, a bottom text,
as well as an image in the URL
bar in order to create a meme.
Now, you can follow along
with your own application
or make use of a sample one
in the description box below.
All right, let's jump into
the first two sections.
First, let's begin by taking a
look at the application code.
Here, we can see the
application code.
And remember that
you can code in any
of your favorite languages,
such as Python, Ruby,
Go, and many more.
And over here we can see the
meme generator service works
by first taking in an
upper text, a bottom text,
as well as an image URL in order
to create and generate a meme.
And next, over here we
also have a Dockerfile
that defines the base image
where it's all being packaged
into a container.
Next, I'm going to
show you how easy it
is to build the container image
by using the builds command.
All right, we're
going to speed this up
a little bit until
it's been done.
And now it's done.
And now we're going to
deploy this onto Cloud Run.
All right, now we're going to
navigate over the Cloud Run.
And here we are right
now in Cloud Run.
And to create a new
Cloud Run service,
you can simply click on
the Create Service button.
And over here, you can
give your service a name,
select the region, as well
as select the container image
that you want to deploy.
In this case, we'll be
selecting the container image
that we have just
built. Following
that, you can just click on
Create in order to deploy.
Now we have our container
image running on Cloud Run.
And here we have our
application up and running.
As you can see, you have
all of the information
that you may need right
at your fingertips,
from the managing
of your revisions,
which we'll get into shortly,
metrics, logs, and many more,
making it really easy for
your startup to manage.
And right now, we're going
to check out our application
simply by clicking on the URL.
And here we can see that our
service is up and running.
We can simply
click on an example
to see how the
application works.
And now we're going
to test it out too,
simply by adding in and editing
the upper text, bottom text,
as well as image URL
to generate a new meme.
And there we have it.
Next, I'm going to
show you how easy it
is to deploy a new version
of the application.
All right, so now we're going
to head back to the application
code and edit it a little
by including a hello, well
as a welcome message.
We're going to
quickly click Save.
And once we're done, we're
going to rebuild this container
image.
We're going to split
this part up a little
until the container image
is being built as well.
And we're done.
And now we're going to
head back to Cloud Run
and redeploy this new revision.
As you can see,
it's really simple.
And you can easily select the
latest container image that you
have just built, and deploy.
And immediately, we're done.
You can see that we have our
new version now up and running
on Cloud Run.
Now moving on to the
third part of our demo.
What if you want the
different versions to serve
different levels of traffic?
Let's take a final look
at traffic splitting.
With Cloud Run, it
is extremely easy
to manage your traffic for
the different revisions
that you may have.
Simply click on Manage Traffic.
And over here, you
can fill out the form
to the different levels
of desired traffic
for your different revisions.
And with that, we are
done with the demo.
Over here, you saw
how easy it was
to not only deploy on
Cloud Run, but to also
manage your revisions, as
well as manage your traffic.
Now you may wonder, what are
the most important things
to take note of for cost
as well as performance?
In this section,
we'll be covering
the best practices
for cost optimization
as well as performance
optimization.
I'll be putting some links in
the description box below as
well for your further reading.
To optimize performance,
first of all,
remember the specified
minimum number
of container instances
you want to be
kept warm and ready
to serve requests.
Secondly, don't
forget to also try
to minimize the number
of dependencies,
as well as the size of them, to
make sure that your service is
a lean one.
Thirdly, lazily load code which
is infrequently being used
if your language supports it.
And also make use of
global variables, as well.
The initialization
of global variables
occurs during the start
up, which can severely
increase the code start time.
Now, one great
example of a variable
that is expensive
to initialize will
be the database connections.
Database connections are great
to keep as global variables.
And finally, make use of
minimal container images.
Larger container images
can increase your security
vulnerabilities.
And this is because they contain
more than what your code needs.
As for cost optimization,
setting the right number
of maximum instances, depending
on your traffic as well as
desired level of
request latency,
can help you to optimize
your overall costs.
Secondly, it is also important
to take note and optimize
your CPU as well as RAM.
CPU usage is generally
a huge contributor
to what your overall costs.
Thirdly, it is also
highly important
to make use of billing
alerts, as well as labels.
Budget alerts provide
an early warning signal
to unexpected
increases in your bill.
And as for labels, labels allow
you to assign a simple text
value to particular resources.
And this allows
you to understand
which are the most
significant contributors
towards your overall bill
to allow you to take action
on them.
On top of that, implementing
basic local caching,
where a local in-memory copy of
frequently loaded or generated
data is being kept, can produce
significant and dramatic
improvements to both cost
as well as performance.
And last but not
least, do not forget
to always make sure you
measure the effectiveness
of your changes so that
you can keep track of them
and continue to improve
and optimize the costs.
Now, let's take a look
at a fictitious use
case of a simple
e-commerce application.
When an order is
being first placed
on the front end, which is
being deployed on Cloud Run,
Cloud Run receives the
request and sends it
over to Pub/Sub, which is an
asynchronous messaging service.
The subsequent
microservices, which
are also deployed
on the Cloud Run,
can then subscribe to
these Pub/Sub events.
These microservices
can then make calls
to the other parts
of the architecture.
As you can see in the
examples over here.
And if we wanted to take a
look at a real life example,
we have Arabesque AI.
Arabesque AI provides AI
driven asset management.
And, amongst other
incredible results,
they were able to reduce their
server costs with Cloud Run.
And not only that,
they were also
able to automate
infrastructure management,
resulting in higher
productivity.
All in all, Google Cloud
is able to help you
with the streamlining of
your application development.
Now I hope that today's
session has given you
a good understanding
and overview,
as well as how you
can get started.
And after this video, if you are
keen to find out more and you
cannot get enough of
application development,
feel free to check out
the suggestions here,
as well as the links in
the description below.
And in the next
episode, you'll be
able to learn more
about containerization,
how to deploy on the Google
Kubernetes Engine, optimization
of performance, as well
as look through a sample
architecture, as well as
a customer case study.
All right, and that's
a wrap for today.
See you in the next video.
[MUSIC PLAYING]